thank you
[Music]
weird welcome back to another um
with careful boys today we have Walter
Colleen can't hello Nick and uh we're
missing a few people but that's okay
let's take one all right there was there
was this thing I wanted to ask you guys
I think like a few weeks ago but we
didn't get to it but like uh you guys
ever been down a YouTube rabbit hole for
anything yes where you just couldn't
stop watching and learning and trying to
like get deeper Iceberg information on
something sure it wasn't it wasn't to
find nudity
um
although they do have a nudity on
YouTube yeah they have those secret
links it oh dude
like everything I was talking about
whatever whatever they do like naked
protests they can't censor oh yeah yeah
no it's not that they have like um like
they'll have secret links and then you
know once it's caught obviously it's
shut down but then they'll just keep on
oh like I'll list it so what does your
rabbit hole start and then we're gonna
do yeah how did you find that what what
this you weren't looking up bull I
wasn't looking at it
because it's obviously
yeah there's easier but you know
sometimes I like to work imagine if we
had to tell them you know there's porn
sites right I understand what do you
mean
this whole time
with porn on it for free because I use
VHS
are you typing what was your what was
your that's racist bro what would you do
what was your Deep dive like what were
you looking up so we I told you guys
recently I've been in the fountain pens
that wasn't a joke no I thought it was
like a dorky nerd joke
I'm not a dorky nerd okay
[Laughter]
you're a fountain pen jock
hey let me tell you something just
because the fountain pen read it so
Community is mostly women
doesn't mean that I I am oh that's why
you do it because it's mostly women you
could probably hit up that Community my
boy I am part of the Summer's Eve
Community
it's a douche brand oh shut up yeah why
do you know that
[Laughter]
how did you get into fountain pens of
all things okay so my stupid friend have
you guys have you guys heard of the
Traveler's company no they make
Travelers notebooks Travelers yeah so
it's called the Traveler's company uh it
started with they're called midori's
Original company but they broke off in
the childish company they make travel
notebooks basically you take these
leather bound notebooks and you can put
inserts in and you go travel and you you
document your travels okay yeah so I had
something like that for my notes like
when I write down bids and whatnot cool
so she got me into that and then she
goes oh and then he found pencil no
don't even no I'm already down this
traveler notebook thing don't do found
pens yeah she's like no but they're
really cool so I'm like so on Amazon you
can buy like a to dip your toe you can
buy an eight dollar fountain pen when it
comes with cartridges and everything
it's all like you know self-contained so
I used it and I wrote with it and it
felt like a mechanical pencil yeah but
it was purple ink that's cool and I got
intrigued so then I started kept going I
kept going I and I and then this
company's jinhao it's your people's
company and then I went to another
jinhao model so this one I got the x450
and then I got the x159 because I have
arthritic hands and then so these are
girthier pens they weighted these aren't
waiting yes so like is that in the
marketing it actually marketing
so like wait in the subreddit Community
when they're talking about these pens do
they use the term girth a lot they do
yeah they don't say it's a girthier pan
or they'll say it's a fat pen
um that's what they'll say
original I just wanted to make sure
I use girth a lot because you know
selling points but anyhow
so this pen wrote really smooth so I'm
like oh there's different and I'm just
learning about fountain pen so I'm like
oh there's different characteristics I
started looking them up yeah so they
started going on YouTube like how to
maintain the pen how to fix the pen and
then I kept going to like different
models because the Japanese make uh
really nice ones so I started typing in
the models and then I started like
looking at videos and people have like
commentary reviews and then next thing I
know it's like two in the morning and
I'm just like whoa dude what are you
doing is there is there like a certain
Tech that you're supposed to write with
those type of pens because I know that
like a lot of the if you press too hard
it comes out thicker there's Flex nibs
yeah which if you press harder you'll
get a thicker line that sounds racist
and then there's food a nibs which are
bed nibs I'm saying nibs
remember it's Nippon not nibon
[Laughter]
but there's food
and hold it perpendicular yeah yeah you
get you get a thin line and the more
angle you hold it it'll be a thicker
line that's crazy and then there's like
some that the feed the pen more ink so
you're into fountain pens too then no
I'm not but how do you know so much I
did I get it's a brush pens like ink and
stuff yeah and then one of the options
was the pen nibs what are they called
like uh just Fountain they're dipping
pens okay because there's ones where you
dip but there's one that's already
loaded too those are found hey what
about a one with a feather on it you
know
how does the fountain pen Community
think about those idiots with quills
actually okay here's the funny do they
[__] on them like what a bunch of the
fan pen Community everyone's so
supportive oh everyone
yeah 15 people will call them out on it
um if you go to the Tesla Community
people are mean like you have to
question they're like really you're
gonna ask that like just do your
research like it's a whole bunch of
typical so what's an example of someone
being mean in the fountain banking
people
um I don't like this color someone will
say do your research and then that's
kind of like you know that's kind of
people won't say anything they'll just
they'll just respond to the question
but where's the other side so people
will say they'll like clap back you know
at the person the founding Community
they'll just they'll just answer the
question does that Community talk in
like fountain pen puns sometimes
um there's not a lot of jokes because
it's hard to do jokes that's already a
joke yeah oh man
I have to rethink things
oh do you ever watch a fountain pen you
watch fountain pen like videos of guys
talking boxes
you make it sound so like that I'm gonna
start no I just didn't know that you
should start doing that no but um
it's mostly women okay now I don't want
to [__] on it is between the gel pen
community no you know gel pen Community
is posers like like they're [__]
losers
that's like Sanrio Girls huh yeah yeah
yeah there is no Community I like that
fountain pen like I said the founding
Community is very supportive so like but
you don't ask gel pen questions in the
fountain pen right thank you that
belongs in another three yeah but you
will use a different video you will get
this though hey I like this gel pen is
there a fountain pen that's similar to
it you'll get stuff like that okay
[Laughter]
do you like
I never knew that was a thing like I
just Googled our fountain pens cool and
then I saw them
I have an image of my head like because
it comes from school that you like
change the color in the yeah okay that's
I just keep thinking that if you like
gel there's a great multi pen that
carries five inks and there's some that
carry fourings plus a mechanical pen can
I get one without kuropi's head at the
top
or every time I clicking his job opens
heropi is awesome yeah I actually have a
skateboard deck with kuroki on it Hello
Kitty's number two deck has all the
Sanrio characters on it I may or may not
have it is
no but I may or may not have the first
four editions of the Hello Kitty
skateboard are they worthless
the first one is can you give me a
ballpark estimate the last time I
checked it was like 180 damn it's on a
45 deck yeah that's crazy but I don't
know about now because you know you know
you know like okay
crypto goes up
all the that the value of like
basketball cards skateboard decks it all
goes up
crypto goes down all that all that comes
because people aren't trying to buy it
yeah that makes sense any other rabbit
holes do you got one that's Rabbit Hole
um maybe we should not skip you
it's just like searching up stuff on
YouTube and you just keep going yeah
that's a rabbit hole can
we're in YouTube man
okay
I did get into it I did get into uh what
is it called I guess crazy modeling like
oh that's tight yeah I made a bunch of
little like Mario characters or whatever
because like those simple shapes but
then I started looking at videos of like
how do people actually do it you know
and there's there's so much information
there's like professional like sculpting
and then there's just like stuff you do
with like polymer clay where you can
just roll it into a ball and stick it
together so it's like so much
I don't know techniques for just
something but it's really what I pretty
much got from it was like you can pretty
much do it however you want to do it and
figure it out based off of the basics
which is kind of like drawing too but
yeah mix you can mix colors in in with
different
um Clays and you can pretty much just
need like the primary colors and then
you could mess around with that and come
up with you oh you mix your own colors
yeah yeah so you got to know your
combination yeah yeah yeah so it's
interesting because like you would think
that one color would turn into another
color but then it just turns gray and
then you're like oh mixing this is not
the same as light color grading or
anything like on like editing you know
you guys ever do that no nobody I know
color gradient is but you know what a
color wheel it's like there's opposites
if you mix the Opposites together it
just becomes this gray blob but yeah so
red and blue doesn't give you purple
actually I get into a lot of rabbit
holes but I get out of them really
quickly because the one right before the
clay one was pastels like oil pastels oh
yeah quite the artist can thanks you
should get into fountain pens I know a
guy I I it used to yeah I used to always
moved on from that yeah
I went from inking to like comic book
stuff and then I got into pastels and
now I'm into this place next is gonna be
tattoos watch she's gonna start asking
to give up because as long as we've got
one less Viet on the streets yeah
any hobby take any hobby yeah
I don't know that's that was pretty much
what I've been getting into just like
different art mediums because that's
what I think is that's tight yeah no you
are very artsy dude I think you're very
artsy yeah see how supportive of you
guys are with him
it was just joke after a joke afterwards
hope this guy
you guys know Pokemon right no I've
never heard of it and then there's
Digimon I got into Digimon but the
trading card game that's not nerdy it is
why'd you say it like that because it's
a thing we know Digimon your voice is
scary I know I thought you were gonna
deep cut us and be like well it's
because it's not as popular and you have
to be like really into the show and
really into this well it'd be nerdy if
you said card captors or you said like
Mega Man Battle Network I'd be like oh I
got this guy out of here yeah I'm really
sorry but yeah how do you know this
world so extensively he talks a lot
right
yeah now I want to know what Mega Man
don't even worry about it let me tell
you about my rabbit hole there's um so
there's a an online game from way back
in the day it was do you guys remember
Club Penguin I know it's so nerdier than
that there's this one called Habbo Hotel
and it was just a game where like you
you pick an avatar and you go into these
different like pixelated rooms as your
character and you just talk to people
it's like oh really uh very simple but
there was like a thing that happened on
there where like you know like when
memes kind of go overboard and they just
like turn into like a giant activity and
everyone starts participating that
happened on this online community with
something called the pools closed whoa
so in have a hotel there's like a pool
that you can go into and all of a sudden
people would just start blocking the
ladder so you couldn't use the pool and
then they would just say oh the pool's
closed and they would all dress up as
the same character that was in like a
black suit in an Afro so you had like
hundreds of the same looking guy all
blocking the ladder to the pool and they
would just say the pool's closed I'm
walking into the room with Ryan and
they're like Ryan what are you doing
he's like I don't know the pool's closed
I didn't I didn't uh I've been here for
five hours man let me show you let me
just show you what that looks like that
reminds me of VR chat have you ever
gotten to VR chat that [__] was crazy
um it's it's like you're yeah so here's
here's what the game looks like and
here's what the dudes look like that are
blocking the pool what a bunch of trolls
so yeah actually troll but then it
became a thing that would happen in real
life what were people saying right
someone's saying Hitler was oh don't
read that part because it gets there it
gets to that it's so um it was kind of
ruined sorry so because you could say
whatever you want this is like old
school internet so like yeah because you
could say whatever you wanted people
would like it kind of had like a racist
undertone to it yeah overtone I should
say no it's bad but um it moved into the
real world where these people started
calling public pools and they would
prank them and go
yeah hey I'm just a little bit concerned
uh because I had an open cut at your
pool today and I am HIV positive so I
thought maybe you could let them know
not to go in the pool so then all these
pools everywhere were closing because of
the age scare
yeah damn and that was the joke of the
pool's closet the chlorine's supposed to
kill all that your rabbit hole is
walking videos well because have a hotel
was a game I remembered and then I I was
like oh who's hobo hotel are people
still playing it and then there's a
whole rabbit hole about this epidemic
pools like videos on yeah their
experience through it became like really
really huge like uh they would put this
up on like different pools everywhere
it was like a thing with the character
saying pools closed they would just post
that at public pool and then if you know
you know yeah and it was like one of
those one of those things where if you
spotted it people love the inside that's
funny the thing is it's interesting that
all the characters are black because
then like for the Casual person they're
like you know the subconscious is like I
hate black people they're making the
pool closed
they could it could happen
through a TV like if they cut if they
cast like a a character where everyone
hates that character like they do
something wrong and that person's like a
minority yeah and it's easy for people
to watch and go oh I hate that and then
they call that whatever race they are
right you guys ever watch Family Guy
yeah no I watch cartoons I'm a grown man
yeah what's a Family Guy well earlier in
my life I used to watch a lot of the
show and then in the show they all hate
one character named mang right yes and
it's played by the famous me lagunas
right anytime I see her
in a movie just her I always go [__] it
I can't believe it
yeah yeah just because of her voice oh
wow let's go [__] Meg dude I can't
stand her for no reason I have to snap
myself out of it and be like oh wait
you're just being you're being a silly
boy dude there's no reason to hate her
that is true because remember there's a
long-standing thing about making
mystical Asian long beard guys the
villain in all these like different
movies yeah I'm I know that is a that's
definitely an effect I want a mystical
beard but yeah these guys they took they
take it really far like obviously you
can't show this but they would always
stand in that formation particularly oh
my God you know what I mean that's so
good you think it's as a it's a joke or
this seriously like it's a it's a hyper
Mega troll I think they just like trolls
just know what's pushing your button and
they just like yeah Zone in on it yeah
but that's that's one of my favorite
rabbits I think it's so weird it's
quality yeah that reminds me of VR chat
they used to have stuff like that where
um you would so basically basically what
VR chat is it's like a 3D environment
you make an avatar same thing and you go
into these different portals where you
can go to like I don't know a place that
looks like oh you're in Super Mario
World or whatever and then
um there was one where if you go into
these
um
I don't even know what they call Rooms
there there's just a bunch of avatars
that are Knuckles from Sonic you know
Knuckles yeah red dude yeah yeah they're
all Knuckles but they're they have like
these beady eyes you can look it up you
can type in VR chat Knuckles okay and
then everybody has their life like he
always does it oh this one yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that one and then
they would go into this room and have
this Nigerian accent it's like the
Uganda thing yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then they would always go up to each
other oh my queen my queen like my queen
let me show you the way yeah it's from
VR shot and that wasn't one of those
shows
yeah look up a video it's like it's a
deformed Knuckles yeah yeah that's so
funny so you used to run into them
that's silly yeah I used to be in those
rooms I'm like wow this is such an
interesting world like this is what it
would feel like if there were no rules
in this world like people would just do
crazy [__] like this yeah I think no
rules will be the purge yeah definitely
a bunch of idiots like this dude walk
around like Queen McQueen that's kind of
yeah and then they they would do these
things where they would just suicide off
of the map oh it's kind of like but it's
like you're not gonna die but they just
they just get into a line yeah they
would just jump off all right who's next
you know
I think it's good that they're letting
all of this weird
virtual world so that in the real world
you can just be like all right I don't
need to do that here do you think you
think they're not working I think I
think they're yeah yeah yeah yeah I know
it's kind of like I say all my intrusive
thoughts out loud
I'm a strong proponent of that yeah
because think about it you have all
these like weird things in your head and
you can't you have to resist not doing
any of that in the real world so you let
it out so let me ask you a question then
let's take that let's take that like
three steps further and like let's say
incest
yeah okay that's just three that's
normal what are you talking about don't
do that
so like would you rather have because
people talk about this criminalizing
like chat rooms where they talk about it
that's stupid oh yeah yeah because then
then nothing's happening you're just
talking about it it's just air because
what people believe is they'll say oh
because they're talking about it now
we're giving people ideas and
encouraging them and then so don't make
the first step to do it dude
no no here's the thing people will do it
without those yeah yeah
I mean sisters
when I was like 14 or 15 I ran into
weird rooms like that where people were
talking about incest or like I just got
gross sound left so I guess if they
exist and they exist but not everyone
yeah it's gonna be influenced by them
because again I think there's a line
yeah yeah a line I think once again when
you cross organize uh violence and hate
and that's like okay that's [__] up
yeah you know because then it's gonna
transfer isolate to the real world
somehow right but if it's just stuff
where it's like you know incest or
whatever like take it all out what
happened
don't scoff at it he's right next door
you got a proponent right here man make
him an ally I don't know I think people
just need to find an outlet for whatever
like that I do agree with that actually
yeah I mean thank God you're in a
fountain pen you know there was
something right there was this argument
back then about GTA when it first came
out about how like people are like oh
it's gonna cause kids to be more violent
but really they're just letting all
their violent behaviors into the game
you know I mean even then it's just I'm
a big believer in it just being a game
yeah like because that's how I treat it
yeah yeah I feel like when I played GTA
and I run people over on the street what
else do you do I do most of that because
they get in the way and I want when I
drive on the sidewalk I want to drive on
the sidewalk in peace
yeah well when I do that I I just I'm
like yeah hatch it's like it's just a
video game I think it's also because
like in games like let's say you're a
square and you have to move over a
circle I I kind of equate that as a car
running over to person if it's both in a
game yeah it's just an objective
I don't take it like personal like oh
that's a real guy like oh I really want
to do this no it's just not at all
because we all want to how many people
have you heard say that though like when
they when they run over people with
their car they're like oh I was just
pulling I was just copying GTA you know
what if they say that I want to get
their PSN ID and see how many hours
they've actually put what level they are
yeah because if they're not actually
playing that [__] it's not that your
fault though yeah
and you're bringing that into the game
yeah right right and then you know and
people will say like oh you know yeah
like we found out we threw some research
that that guy that ran over the people
played GTA well I'm sorry but GTA is a
super popular game
I know yeah like it doesn't mean
everyone's gonna you know yeah super
popular and you can literally do almost
anything in that game what did they call
that like with the game where you can go
in your sandbox yeah is that what it's
called yeah where there's you could
actually play it without an objective
and just do whatever you want well like
but you can go anywhere like so any any
building you see yeah yeah it's called
sandbox okay well almost in GTA not
every building you can do that but
there's some games you like everything
in the game you can go into you can
interact with yeah you can interact with
every little thing so there's no because
back then like when I played games like
there you see buildings yeah the
background you know what game is really
good at sandbox uh Zelda the new Zelda I
heard that it's really I [__] hate
that because you could see stuff it's
like I wonder if I could climb that and
you can okay see that's cool yeah like
if I played games and uh you know I
wasn't a drone man I think that would be
really fun yeah I think if anything more
more people seem like they've copied
direct crimes out of film than games
yeah I feel like like heists yeah I
always think when I when I hear about a
a failed Heist I'm like y'all watch too
many movies yeah
um why do you think that was gonna work
yeah seriously organized movie but even
then everything you never do in life is
a composite of everything you consume so
you can't blame it on any one thing
right you can't just go like oh that's
true I channeled the rock or something
like that it's like this life imitate
art or does art imitate life like when
you look at like Godfather those mafia
movies all the Italians the mobs dress
really well
the real mob didn't dress that way so
like I remember when you guys watched
Donnie Brasco which only did the Al
Pacino that's how they work they just
were regular like clothes because they
couldn't afford all these like but the
media but media we all ran with it we
all thought oh that's how Mafia dressed
and um I had a writing professor in
college who knew some other guys and
then oh you guys are always dressable
he's like no we dress well because of
the movies that looked great so we
started doing it
so it chicken egged them yeah but we
believed it was based on actual you know
things huh like I remember there's a
Korean um mocking movie called uh New
World great movie and I remember one of
the comments where it's so ridiculous
they're all wearing suits like that's
stupid like why would they do that but
in Korea like that's just kind of like
they were these gaudy outfits and so
everyone recognizes oh they're they're
like we're just gonna stay away and so
it's culturally what people wear we
don't and the thing is we don't know is
did they start doing that because of the
movies or did the movie start portraying
them because they actually did that
right
yeah
the the main thing that remains true is
all the real dudes in any of these
worlds just are the most low-key like
you've even notice like you don't know
how he dresses and and when you're
making a movie about him he's over there
going stop making movies
why do you want to be publicized yeah
yeah it's always a realist dude you're
just the most invisible it's like you
know that Conspiracy Theory with Mel
Gibson uh Julie Roberts uh the richest
man in the world just died yesterday
they're like no the richest man is this
person because no this person drowned
he's not the richest person he's like no
if you were the richest person in the
world would you want people to know yeah
it would make a lot of sense and people
wouldn't even be able to calculate it
yeah because they wouldn't know which
how far out it's spread that's what some
like some conspiracy theories are is
like the richest like people like the
one percent of the one percent no one
knows how much they have yeah I believe
that like uh I did a report on Mafia
when I was in high school the Chinese
mob you're people's mob they made more
off opium just opium than the US had in
total currency this was a 19 like uh 89
1990. and that's just off opium they're
in their their hands are in so many
different things so imagine like the
richest person in the world their hands
are in so many different things there's
no way to calculate no like for Rustica
they know but there's no way for us to
calculate how much they may have or may
not have yeah like I don't think the
richest person in the world is uh who is
it uh
and then there's the guy that owns all
the fashion um stuff I forgot oh the guy
that owns like Zara and everything yeah
oh I forgot his name his his group owns
basically all the top end fashion labels
yeah oh Tommy Bahama
no he's second he's number two yeah yeah
those guys like I don't believe that
they're the richest yeah or the
wealthiest I believe there's some dude
yeah why were some woman I think you're
right yeah
foreign